I recently did a Things You Missed video on
The Nun teaser trailer, so if you haven't
seen that click or tap up here to view that
video.
One of the things I mentioned was how The
Nun has been teased in the other Conjuring
films-- so if you want to see all of those
references -- you know what to do: stick around
to the end of this video.
Starting with the first Conjuring...
I'm gonna regret that if they end up coming
out with a movie called "The First Conjuring"
or some sh-- but starting with The Conjuring,
The Warrens have this room filled with cursed
objects from their previous cases.
It's the room that holds the Annabelle doll
before the Annabelle spin-offs were a thing,
and it also has this picture of a creepy nun.
Keep in mind this is before they face off
against Valak, the Nun demon in The Conjuring
2, so there may be something at the end of
The Nun, where the characters think they've
trapped Valak in this painting, but in reality
it's just some other spirit.
We may also see the event that causes Valak
to hang with the Warren family, a poltergeist
that persists through The Conjuring 2.
Later on if you pause during the scene where
Carolyn Perron hears clapping in the house,
in one of the pictures on the wall, you can
clearly see The Nun standing behind the family...
............. OK, OK, I'm kidding, that's
probably just the daughter.
It does look a bit creepy though, I can't
lie.
I think that's actually it for the first movie
though, this was before we even knew this
would be a big franchise, but I think this
room of trinkets is a clever way to tie the
series together, and we may even see spin-offs
of other objects in this room.
I mean, I know I'd watch a movie about this
monkey...
Wouldn't you?
The next movie to come out was the first Annabelle.
.... OK...
OK, the next movie to come out was Annabelle,
in 2014.
There aren't really any specific references
to the demon Valak, but you can spot some
Nun imagery, like this statue, or this statue
of a nun.
These are probably things that would be there
anyways just because the father of the Church
is such a central character in this movie.
One thing I found that could be significant,
but I'm not entirely sure, is the music that
plays when the record player kicks on towards
the end of the movie.
If you reverse that audio it sound like a
church choir, or perhaps a demonic church
choir, however I'm not sure what language
it's in.
I'm gonna roll this clip, and if you have
any ideas about deciphering it, let me know
in
the comments.
Now The Conjuring 2, as I mentioned, is all
about Valak, so it's obviously going to contain
a lot of appearances, but in the spirit of
the title of this show, I'm gonna stick to
the less obvious ones.
The movie opens with a snippet of The Warrens
investigating the Amityville Haunting, and
as Lorraine has her out of body experience,
you can spot a Nun painting on the bedroom
wall.
There's also a Nun figurine in the daughter's
room and in the basement.
It all leads up to this reveal: Valak has
been haunting Lorraine and her family since
at least 1976.
Then later on in the movie, Lorraine mentions
that the vision she had in Amityville was
the same one she had 7 years ago, meaning
that Valak has been around her family since
at least 1969.
"It was the same one I had 7 years ago.
The demon in your painting is real.
We have both seen the same inhuman spirit.
It's a warning.
If we keep doing this, you're going to die."
Weird stuff starts happening after Ed Warren
wakes up from a dream in which he saw the
demon, and couldn't get it out of his head.
The name Valak starts appearing everywhere.
First on the wall in the kitchen, then the
daughter's arts and crafts.
A couple nights later letters appear in the
study, where another Nun statue appears.
During one of Lorraine's visions, she ends
up writing the name in her bible during a
state of panic.
After the Warrens head out to England to try
to help the Hodgson family, there's scene
where the church choir music originally heard
in Lorraine's vision can be heard coming from
the kitchen of the Hodgson house and the daughter
Janet claims to see a pair of eyes hiding
in the dark.
This is most likely her first vision of Valak
in it's Nun form.
Valak tells her to destroy the kitchen to
get the public to believe that the whole thing
was a hoax and reduce the possibility of invention
from the church, but the chapel music and
the sounds of knives sharpening tells me that
she really does see the demon hiding in the
dark.
It's not long after that when Ed and Lorraine
realize the spirit of the old man haunting
the house is being controlled by the demon,
and everything after that is quite obvious...
That is... until the end credits.
The end title sequence is accompanied by a
series of photos, some of which compare the
actors in the movie to their real life counterparts
as you might often see in "based on a true
story" films.
The photos are displayed on an old slide projector,
so when switching from photo to photo, there
is a bit of a gap that lasts a fraction of
a second.
Sometimes though, instead of seeing the transitioning
projector in between frames, an image is displayed.
It's usually a photo of the house, and some
of them contain the old man sitting on the
chair.
If you pause at just the right moment or go
frame by frame, one of these photos shows
the demon Valak standing over the old man's
body.
I was actually somewhat startled to come across
this, because I had no idea it was there.
Another frame spliced in depicts the demon
standing at the end of the hall, as seen earlier
in the movie at the Warren residence.
I don't know why, but the face is blurred
in each of these photos, and nothing else.
Here's another shot that is displayed one
frame later, this one could be more of a teaser
toward The Nun.
Aaaand then there's this lovely portrait,
which is the last one before the credits roll
and we move on to Annabelle Creation.
And it takes place way before everything else,
meaning that it's closer to the time period
that The Nun is set in.
The name of the Nun who watches over the orphan
girls is Sister Charlotte, and in one scene
she tells about a photograph that was taken
when she was in Romania of her and three other
sisters.
Keep in mind that Romania is where the next
movie is set, so this is probably a direct
reference to characters who will appear in
the next film.
"That's sister Maria, that's sister Anna,
and that's sister Lucia."
"Who's this?"
"I don't know.
I don't think I even met her."
Yeah, excuse me, I think I have a couple ideas.
But yeah, as I mentioned in the previous video,
there's also a post credits sequence set
at that Abbey in Romania, which is also seen
in the teaser for The Nun.
If you like this kind of video, well, then
obviously drop me a like, but there's also
this video I did where I talk about everything
in JIGSAW that sets up for the next installment
in the Saw franchise, so if you're interested
in that, you know, you could always give that
one a watch.
Just a suggestion.
If you're new to the channel, welcome.
Feel free to hit that subscribe button for
new horrors every week, I've got more Things
You Missed, scary stories and short films,
so make sure you ring that deathbell for notifications
and I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.